[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
wenn es die Russen waren und davon gehen
auch die westlichen Regierungen aus dann
war es eine monströse Tat einen Damm zu
sprengen und einen zu diesem Zeitpunkt
maximal gefüllten riesigen Stausee zu
fluten auf das der Felder Dörfer und
Städte überflutet das wäre ein
gewaltiges Kriegsverbrechen und ist eine
Katastrophe für Mensch und Natur mit
noch unabsehbaren Folgen Christian von
Rechenberg und gar nicht Sternberg
berichten
sein Video startete sagt er stand er
noch nicht im Wasser jetzt mittendrin
und es steigt weiter
die Katastrophe ist da der kachowa
weggespült fortgetragen 18 Milliarden
Kubikmeter Wasser hat er zurückgehalten
bis heute Nacht bis irgendwas geschah
es ist physikalisch unmöglich die Anlage
von außen durch Beschuss irgendwie in
die Luft zu jagen sie wurde vermiet sie
wurde von den russischen Besatzern
verdient und sie haben sie in die Luft
gesprengt
Russland widerspricht sagt die Ukraine
waren's Beweise hat keiner keine Bilder
von Raketen oder Explosionen nur so viel
scheint klar mehr als ein Jahr Krieg
sind an dem umkämpften Staudamm nicht
ohne Spuren vorbeigegangen
ist ganz stark noch mal angestiegen das
heißt selbst wenn jetzt heute Nacht
nicht die Entscheidung der Explosion
stattgefunden hat was aber auch sein
kann dann ist dieser Stau dann jetzt
schon seit Monaten unter sehr großen
physischen Einwirkungen und so wälzt
sich seit Stunden eine Wasserwand den
hier pro hinab Richtung krasson dieses
Modell zeigt wie schlimm es kommen
könnte knapp 100 Ortschaften heißt es
liegen in der Risikozone die Heimat von
knapp 40.000 Menschen
rettet euer Leben die Botschaft ist
Militär gewonnen das von gestern das ist
früher Morgen die Menschen haben ein
paar Stunden um das aller Nötigste
zusammen zu packen die Rettungsaktion
läuft dann immerhin auf dieser Seite des
Flusses steigt das Wasser
verhältnismäßig langsam
da drüben auf der anderen Seite sagt
dieser Mann da schwimmen sie
wahrscheinlich schon
da drüben ist Russisch besetztes Gebiet
in der Stadt Nova kachowa direkt am
Staudamm steht das Wasser 10 Meter hoch
und höher sagt der Bürgermeister
bestätigen lässt sich das kaum ob es
Tote gibt nicht ausgeschlossen wissen
werden wir es wohl erst in den nächsten
Tagen Experten auch welche Schäden die
Natur genommen hat
eines der größten in Europa das jetzt
mit diesen Wassermassen überschwemmt
wird das also
große Mengen haben zum Beispiel Dinge
Rückständen aber eben auch Kraftstoffen
und einfach ziehen Müll jetzt in dieses
Gebiet hineinträgt das wird auch dort
die Ökologie sehr stark
stören das Reserve vor dem karowka
Staudamm versorgt die ganze Gegend mit
Wasser auch das AKW ist aber sicher
Kühlwasser sei noch genug da vorher erst
woanders könnte Wasser fehlen im
nord-kanal er versorgt die von Russland
besetzte Halbinsel ohne den Staudamm
könnte es vor allem für die
Landwirtschaft kritisch werden
und so kennt der Dammbruch heute nur
Verlierer und der Westen einen
Schuldigen
das ist ein empörender Vorgang der
erneut die ganze Brutalität des
russischen Krieges gegen die Ukraine
zeigt
der Damm von wem zerstört oder warum von
selbst eingebrochen Fragen die warten
müssen im Moment geht es am mirpro ums
Überleben
dem Krüger ist für uns sind die
Überschwemmungsgebiete gefahren und
jetzt live aus herson zugeschaltet den
bei dir ist es sehr dunkel aus
Sicherheitsgründen nicht viel Licht was
hast du in den letzten Stunden erlebt
und gesehen
also wir sind hier am späten Nachmittag
in die Stadt reingefahren und wir sind
dann gleich in Richtung Fluss gefahren
aber schon einige hundert Meter vor dem
eigentlichen schussbett stand dann schon
das Wasser so dass wir nicht
weiterfahren konnten also da war
eigentlich schon klar dass Dutzende
Straßenzüge überschwemmt waren
überflutet waren schon zu diesem
Zeitpunkt und dennoch war die Situation
in der Stadt hier eigentlich relativ
ruhig auch die Menschen die wir
getroffen haben wirken noch relativ
ruhig auch wenn sie natürlich entsetzt
waren über die Zerstörung des Dampfs und
über diese Überflutung in der Stadt es
ist allerdings auch so dass viele
Bewohner von Hassan nach dem Ende der
Besatzung durch die Russen im
vergangenen Jahr noch nicht in die Stadt
zurückgekehrt sind ganz einfach deswegen
weil diese Stadt auch nach der Befragung
im vergangenen Jahr noch immer sehr
heftig beschossen wird das war übrigens
auch jetzt heute Abend so wir haben
Explosionen gehört die ganz offenbar
durch Beschuss von russischer Seite her
standen es ist jetzt so dass die
Behörden ganz offenbar davon ausgehen
dass hier morgen früh der Scheitel
dieser Überflutungen erreicht sein wird
dann wird das Wasser ganz langsam in den
kommenden Tagen mehr oder weniger
vollständig abfließen und ich denke dass
man dann wirklich erst das ganze Ausmaß
und auch die Schäden sehen wird die
diese Überflutung hier in der Stadt
Herxheim angerichtet haben eine Stadt
übrigens die schon seit weit mehr als
einem Jahr ganz massiv unter diesem
Krieg leidet Dankeschön für diese
Eindrücke und eine sichere Nacht in
Hassan
eine große Frage ist natürlich auch was
diese Katastrophe für die militärische
Lage in dem Krieg bedeutet ob sie den
vermuteten Verursachern den Russen nutzt
so ziemlich ein solches Kalkül auch ist
darüber wollen wir jetzt mit dem
Sicherheitsexperten Nico lange sprechen
aber unter der vorherigen
Bundesregierung Chef des leitungsstabs
im Bundesverteidigungsministerium kennt
die Ukraine gut hat wird lange das
Auslandsbüro der Konrad Adenauer
Stiftung geleitet kennt aber auch
Russland gut guten Abend Herr Lange
genau
wie sehr kann diese Überschwemmung die
anstehende ukrainische Offensive aus dem
Tritt bringen wie schätzen Sie das ein
es scheint für die Russen darum zu gehen
Zeit zu gewinnen möglicherweise das
Momentum der beginnenden ukrainischen
Offensive zu brechen und es geht auch
darum eine Überquerung des Depot zu
verhindern bei reson das könnte ein
Ablenkungsangriff sein der Ukraine die
Ukraine hält ihre Pläne zurecht geheim
und Russland kann natürlich jetzt auch
Kräfte aus diesem Gebiet abziehen und
kann damit die Front verstärken zum
Beispiel im Süden im Gebiet saporicia
oder im Osten im donpass und man sieht
hier auch den Unterschied die Ukraine
möchte ihre Gebiete befreien und wieder
aufbauen und Russland ist ganz zynisch
dazu bereit das fremde Land Ukraine zu
zerstören also quasi verbrannte Erde
wobei das jetzt jeden schlechter
Vergleich ist überflutete Erde wäre dann
wohl die bessere Formulierung
Russland ist ja in der Propaganda schon
seit vielen Monaten der Auffassung wenn
man die Ukraine schon nicht haben kann
da muss man sie kaputt machen und von
dem Staudamm in novocachowa hängt zum
Beispiel auch das Bewässerungssystem für
den Süden der Ukraine ab viele Kanäle
die für die Landwirtschaft sorgen in der
Ukraine ich habe heute mit vielen
Freunden und Bekannten gesprochen
herrscht große Betroffenheit man ist
schockiert über die Zerstörung der Natur
aber auch über die Zerstörung der
Lebensgrundlagen der Felder der der
Tiere und all dem was viele Ukraine
kennen und was sie auch lieben an ihrer
Heimat es wird auch gesagt dass damit
die Wasserversorgung auf der Krim
eingeschränkt wäre
das stimmt russland hatte allerdings zu
diesem Staudamm und zu dem Kanal der von
diesem Staudamm Weg führte zur Krim
keinen Zugang bis zur russischen
Invasion im Jahr 2022 und es ist nicht
so dass sofort akute Probleme auftauchen
würden das geht im Übrigen auch für das
besetzte bettianske im Süden der Ukraine
und es scheint so dass das Leben der
Menschen in den besetzten Gebieten auf
der Krim für Russland weniger wichtig
ist als jetzt taktische militärische
Gewinne die man vielleicht erzielen kann
durch so eine Aktion es wäre ja auch
wenn es so ist nicht das erste Mal in
der Geschichte von Kriegen dass man eine
Naturkatastrophe gewissermaßen
willentlich herbeiführt also stalin hat
ähnliches 1941 gemacht auch an die Pro
um die deutsche Wehrmacht aufzuhalten ja
und dieser völlig Gruppe lose Umgang
auch mit den eigenen Menschen das ist
etwas was wir in diesem Krieg durch
Russland schon leider sehr häufig erlebt
haben
und die besonders betroffenen sind jetzt
die Ukrainerinnen Ukraine auf dem linken
Ufer des Depot das teilweise unter dem
Meeresspiegel liegt wo das Wasser
hinfließt und während auf der
ukrainischen Seite geholfen wird hat man
den Eindruck auf dem linken Ufer die
Menschen den wird nicht geholfen die
russischen Streitkräfte ziehen ab
niemand kümmert sich und es gab sogar
Berichte heute dass die russischen
Streitkräfte verhindern dass die Leute
dieses Gebiet verlassen
danke für das Gespräch
der Zufall will es dass in Deutschland
gerade heute eine Konferenz zu einer
anderen wasserkatastrophe abgehalten
wird die im vergangenen Sommer für
Entsetzen sorgte als tonnenweise tote
Fische in der oder Trieben nach
Schätzungen starb bis zur Hälfte des
gesamten Fischbestandes inzwischen hat
sich der Zustand der oder wieder
verbessert aber die Sorge bleibt dass
sich die Katastrophe in diesem Sommer
wiederholt die Zusammenarbeit mit der
polnischen Seite lässt dabei zu wünschen
übrig wie auch bei der Konferenz heute
in Brandenburg ersichtlich war Jan Meyer
berichtet
die oder gehört derzeit wohl zu den am
besten überwachten Flüssen nicht weil
sie Staatsgrenze ist sondern
Forschungsgegenstand auf diesem Boot
untersuchen Wissenschaftler Fischbestand
und Wasserqualität Forscher in Berlin
konnten nachweisen dass die gefährliche
goldalge im ganzen Fluss verbreitet ist
der sich nur langsam von der Katastrophe
erholt Messergebnisse und
Satellitenfotos bilden eine Art
Frühwarnsystem wir schauen uns also
regelmäßig Luftbilder an auf dem man
eine Massenentwicklung von allen im
Oberlauf oder mittelllauf sehr schön
sehen würde dann gibt es ja automatische
Messstation entlang der Oder also
zumindest auf dem deutschen Abschnitt im
Polen werden jetzt erst gebaut und da
sieht man auch sehr schön wenn da viele
Algen runterkommen noch ist es in diesem
Jahr nicht so weit doch Messungen zeigen
schon wieder eine erhöhten Salzgehalt an
die Bundesumweltministerin schlägt Alarm
für die salzeinleitungen ist die
polnische Seite zuständig gewesen und
ich bin in Sorge dass die salzeinleitung
zu hoch sein könnten und wenn dann
wieder Hitze auftritt und die Alge ja
weiterhin im Fluss vorhanden ist wie
eine Wiederholung erleben könnten im
vergangenen August wurden in dem
artenreichen Fluss schätzungsweise 360
Tonnen Fische getötet vergiftet durch
die Gold Alge die hatte sich plötzlich
ausgebreitet weil polnische
Bergbaubetriebe salzhaltiges Abwasser
einleitenden ausgerechnet zu einer Zeit
als die oder so wenig Wasser führte wie
selten sonst trotz der Katastrophe
schütten Bagger am polnischen Ufer
weiter steinladungen in den Fluss sogar
in der leicht Zeit wird so die Fahrrinne
verengt der Flusslauf vertieft die
polnische Regierung hält am Ausbau der
oder zur leistungsfähigen Wasserstraße
fest sie schickte keinen Vertreter auf
die Deutsch polnische Konferenz heute in
Schwedt zuletzt hieß es aus Warschau nur
polnische Häfen dar unter der Hafen
Stettin verzeichnen Rekord
umschlagswerte Investitionen an der Oder
verbessern die wirtschaftliche
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit Polens und der
polnischen Regionen lediglich polnische
Lokalpolitiker aus der benachbarten wo
ihr Botschaft kamen heute nach Schwedt
sieht teilen die Sorge um den Fluss
auch wir leben in Angst vor dem was noch
passieren könnte dennoch immer haben wir
unsere Behörden die Schuldigen für die
Katastrophe nicht benannt
derzeit ist es an der oder so schön dass
die Ministerin selfies macht die Grünen
Politikerin möchte dass das so bleibt
auch deswegen trifft sie sich morgen
nicht weit von hier mit ihrer polnischen
Amtskollegin
und jetzt geht's bei dir erstmal weiter
Heinz mit anderen Nachrichten des Tages
und es Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
ist in Indien zu Gesprächen über eine
engere Zusammenarbeit insbesondere im
Bereich Rüstung Indien sei ein besonders
wichtiger strategische Partner für
Europa und auch für Deutschland und
müsse dem zufolge auch so behandelt
werden sagte historius nach Gesprächen
mit seinem Amtskollegen singen aktuell
bezieht Indien rund 60% seiner
Rüstungsgüter noch aus Russland
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat nach einem
gemeinsamen Essen mit dem französischen
Präsidenten macron die
deutsch-französische Freundschaft
gewürdigt am Abend hatte der Kanzler
macron in Potsdam empfangen bei dem
Treffen dürfte es unter anderem um die
Ukraine und Vorschläge der EU-Kommission
für eine Reform der Schuldenregeln
gegangen sein Anfang Juli kommt macron
dann zum ersten Staatsbesuch eines
französischen Präsidenten seit 23 Jahren
wieder nach Deutschland
der Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte hat Russland wegen
mangelhafter Ermittlungen nach der
Vergiftung des Oppositionsführers
Alexander walny zu einer
Entschädigungszahlung von 40.000 Euro
verurteilt der russischen Behörden
hätten nicht ausreichend ermittelt so
die Begründung Hinweise auf ein
mögliches politisches Motiv sein Licht
untersucht worden am Vormittag hat ein
neues Verfahren wegen angeblichen
Extremismus gegen den Inhaftierten
Außenministerin bärburg hat Pläne für
eine eu-asylreform gegen Kritik als ihre
eigenen Partei verteidigt am Rande ihres
Besuchs in Brasilien sagte bärburg
selbst wenn sie selber grenzverfahren
nicht für die richtige Option halte
seien diese Gespräche über
grenzverfahren die einzige Möglichkeit
derzeit in der Europäischen Union zu
einer gerechten Verteilung von
geflüchteten zu kommen in einem Brief an
die Parteispitze hatten rund 730
Mitglieder der Grünen die Pläne
kritisiert laut einem Spiegelbericht
haben auch etwa 30 Bundes-
mehr als 30 Jahre nach dem Brandanschlag
auf eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft in
Saarlouis hat die Bundesanwaltschaft
einen weiteren Verdächtigen festnehmen
lassen dem 54-Jährigen werden Beihilfe
zum Mord und zu versuchte Maut zu Last
gelegt er vertrete eine von
nationalsozialistischen und
rassistischen Überzeugungen geprägte
Ideologie im September 91 war im
Treppenhaus nachts Benzin entzündet
worden bei dem Feuer wurden ein
27-jähriger Asylbewerber aus Ghana
getötet und zwei Hausbewohner verletzt
die Vorwürfe von Machtmissbrauch und
sexuelle Missbrauch gegen die Gruppe
Ramstein bzw ihren Frontmann Till
Lindemann schlagen ja seit Tagen hohe
Wellen und seitdem Süddeutsche Zeitung
und NDR ihrer Recherchen veröffentlicht
haben wiederholt sich ein Muster das
schon bei me too Skandalen in anderen
Branchen zu beobachten war das den
beteiligten Frauen vorgehalten wird sie
hätten doch wissen müssen worauf sie
sich einlassen tatsächlich
müssen Frauen die zu einer
backstage-party eingeladen werden davon
ausgehen dass sie sich genauso gut
direkt auf einen Straßenstrich stellen
könnten
so jedenfalls beschreibt jetzt eine neue
Zeugin ihrer Erfahrungen bei einem
randsteinkonzert deine Bekannte
Youtuberin berichtet wie sie davon
ausging dass sie zu einer coolen
VIP-Party mit Weltstars gehe und wie
geschockt und überrumpelt sie von der
Situation war der sie sich dann
plötzlich befunden habe ein bizarres
Setting das beängstigend und
erniedrigend gewesen sein in München
soll es morgen das nächste Rammstein
Konzert geben von dort berichtet Stefan
leifert
Himmel und Hölle lagen in der Musik von
Rammstein schon immer nah beieinander
vier Konzerte eine viertel Millionen
Zuschauer
München zur Olympiastadion wird ab
morgen Ort eines Kults der vielleicht
gerade seine Unschuld verliert immer
mehr junge Frauen machen öffentlich was
sie hinter der Bühne und nach dem
Konzert erlebt haben boah das ist echt
ein schweres Video erst gestern Abend
postet sein millionenfach geteiltes
Video es soll ihre eigene Geschichte
erzählen die anderer wiedergeben und es
beschreibt ein vermeintliches Muster das
wird jedes Mal bei der Pre-Party ein
Mädchen von Till ausgesucht mit dem er
Sex haben will oder die ihm einen blasen
soll
rammstein-sänger Till Lindemann wird
vorgeworfen sich bei aftershow-partys
junge Frauen zuführen zu lassen ohne
deren Zustimmung oder Wissen aus einem
rosero genannten Teil des Zuschauerraums
seien die Mädchen für ihn rekrutiert
worden mehrere berichten von
Einschüchterung sexuellen Handlungen und
Einsatz von Drogen
[Musik]
mir wurde nicht gesagt dass ich hier
gerade Teil einer potenziellen Orgie
werde
gestellt da sind auch andere Leute ja
ist das eine normale Party es ist hier
nichts wurde mir davon gesagt dass ich
irgendwie mit einem Umkleidekabine mit
zwei couches und Alkohol mit meinem
Handy abgegeben mit irgendwie von telen
Mann ausgesucht werden soll und so ein
Scheiß da wusste ich okay ich muss hier
sofort raus es war die ihre Entscheidung
die mit ihren Post die Welle der
Vorwürfe los trat
nachdem sie Sex mit Lindemann abgelehnt
habe sei ihr Bewusstsein geschwunden
Lindemann habe sie nicht angefasst
dennoch sei sie mit Hämatomen aufgewacht
die angeblich vom Abend stammen woher
genau weiß sie nicht
der Fall Rammstein erzählt viel über
ferntum stark holt und macht Missbrauch
aber auch über eine neue Kultur des
Hinschauens die auch an Rammstein nicht
mehr vorbei geht
das Machtstrukturen die natürlich im
Besonderen in so einem Bereich wie
Fantom und das Verhältnis von Fans zum
Star zum Tragen kommen weil da natürlich
die jemand der Fan ist im Prinzip von
dem anderen was möchte von dem Star was
möchte und dem nah sein möchte und sich
deswegen auch viel gefallen lässt
tagelang äußerten sich weder Sänger noch
Management in einem Statement heißt es
lediglich die Vorwürfe würden sehr ernst
genommen und dann beteiligt euch nicht
an öffentlichen vorurteilungen jeglicher
Art denen gegenüber die Anschuldigungen
erhoben haben sie haben ein Recht auf
ihre Sicht der Dinge wir die Band haben
aber auch ein recht nämlich ebenfalls
nicht vorverurteilt zu werden
auch Anwälte soll Rammstein nun
eingeschaltet haben von Ermittlungen ist
bisher nichts bekannt es gilt die
Unschuldsvermutung die Stadt München
drängt auf ein Sicherheitskonzept sagt
die vier Rammstein Konzerte aber nicht
ab der Zeit gibt es hier keine
Rechtsgrundlage für eine Absage und
deswegen haben wir uns Gedanken gemacht
wie wir präventiv solche
Großveranstaltungen einfach für alle
sicherer machen können die Stadt hat
eine Rose Zero für das Olympia-Stadion
nun kurzfristig untersagt morgen beginnt
der Rammstein Konzert Marathon in
München lange nicht waren die
Scheinwerfer so auf das Geschehen hinter
der Bühne gerichtet
mit Wirtschaft geht es jetzt weiter
bereits nach dem schwachen
Konjunkturverlauf Ende letzten Jahres
und im ersten Quartal dieses Jahres wird
aufmerksam darauf geschaut wie der Staat
ins zweite Quartal verlaufen ist also
jetzt im April und dazu gibt es jetzt
Zahlen zu den Auftragseingängen der
deutschen Industrie bei der realer wie
sind die Daten aus nicht besonders gut
ein Ökonom sprach von einer riesen
Enttäuschung man hatte eigentlich mit
einer Erholung der Auftragseingänge
gerechnet das ist ein Warnsignal denn
die Industrie ist eine wichtige Stütze
ohne sie wäre die Wirtschaft zu
Jahresanfang noch stärker geschrumpft
schon der März war schwierig da waren
die Aufträge regelrecht eingebrochen um
fast 11 Prozent im Vergleich zum
Vormonat immer April nun noch mal einen
Rückgang um 0,4% ein kleines Minus zwar
aber es zeigt die Industrie hängt in
einer Schwächephase fest da der
Welthandel zurzeit weitgehend stagniert
ist rasche Besserung auch nicht in Sicht
und was kann man daraus ablesen also
Stichwort Rezessionsgefahr ja die
Bundesregierung rechnet ja für 2023 noch
mit einem kleinen wachstumökonomen von
Banken sind da pessimistischer einige
gehen inzwischen davon aus dass die
deutsche Wirtschaft auch im Gesamtjahr
schrumpfen wird schwache Exporte maue
Weltkonjunktur auch hat sich die
Stimmung in den Chefetagen laut
Ifo-Institut deutlich verschlechtert und
die volle Auswirkung der gestiegenen
Zinsen und der hohen Inflation wird sich
in den kommenden Monaten noch zeigen
einiges spricht derzeit also eher für
eine Rezession dieses Jahr aber
ausgemachte Sache ist das natürlich noch
nicht
vielen Dank
eine Meldung aus der Fußball-Bundesliga
wo ist ja Mönchengladbach hat eine neuen
Trainer verpflichtet den früheren
Leverkusener Coach gerade oder sionale
Sie Anne er folgt auf Daniel
die Sängerin Astrid Gilberto ist tot sie
starb nach Medienberichten bereits
gestern im Alter von 83 Jahren in den
USA
weltberühmt machte sie das Lied the girl
from Ipanema das auch mit einem Grammy
ausgezeichnet wurde
[Musik]
nächste Woche starten in Berlin die
Special Olympics Deutschland ist
erstmals Gastgeber der Welt Sommerspiele
für Athleten und Athletinnen mit
geistigen oder mehrfachen Behinderungen
während bei den Paralympics in erster
Linie Sportler mit körperlichen
Einschränkungen antreten und es dabei im
Vorfeld auch eine besten Auswahl gibt
sind die Special Olympics für jeden
offen auch für Athleten die keine
nationalen Wettbewerbe gewonnen haben
und auch für Menschen ohne Behinderungen
wenn Sie Lust haben als sogenannte
Partner mitzumachen inklusion ist hier
der zentrale Begriff und mit ihm spielt
auch der Titel eines Dokumentarfilms der
vier teilnehmende porträtiert all
inclusive
Sven Rücken hat sich angesehen
Treffen mit Timo ein lebensfroher
lustiger junger Mann 26 Jahre alt ich
bin
Sven und ist
Produkttester in einer Werbeagentur timo
hat Trisomie 21
er wohnt in einer Zweier-WG Mama
Cornelia wohnt um die Ecke und ist zur
Stelle wenn es sein muss erinnere mich
an das schicke Ding als du die Brötchen
in die Mikrowelle gesteckt hast
wunderbar also da ging eben halt die
Feuermelder an ich habe einmal getestet
mein Ziel ist 2013 die Weltspiele
mitmachen er in doppelt mit meiner
Schwester zusammen wie gut Timo Tennis
spielt ist nicht so wichtig bei den
Special Olympics geht es um Gemeinschaft
auch für tollwo aus Finnland wenn man
segeln vergisst man alles andere die
ganzen Sorgen und den Alltag auch
Schulzeug einfach alles er hat das
Asperger Syndrom für ujanga in der
Mongolei mit einer Sprachstörung und
Mary Stella aus Kenia die mit einem
Tumor im Kopf lebt vier Länder drei
Kontinente 1000 Probleme in meiner
Familie habe nur ich diese Behinderung
haben meine Eltern mich verflucht oder
haben ihre Eltern sie verflucht
und was wir auch in Austausch mit
unseren Protagonisten nicht nur mit Team
auch mit den anderen immer wieder fahren
haben dass man sich auf Augenhöhe
begegnet also das das nicht über Leute
mit dabei Einrichtungen gesprochen wird
sondern mit ihnen wenn das irgendwie in
der Gesellschaft noch ein bisschen mehr
ankommt dann sind wir vielleicht so ein
bisschen auf dem Weg das dass dieses Gut
dieser große Begriff Inklusion dann
tatsächlich auch ein bisschen mit Leben
gefüllt wird
wenn man mit mir
normalen Mädchen
spricht macht mich das sehr glücklich in
den Ländern von Mary Stella und janga
Timo und Heu das war gut wird Inklusion
sehr unterschiedlich gelebt der Film
fängt aus grenzung und bürokratische
Hürden ein aber eben auch Fürsorge und
Gemeinschaft alles verknüpft mit dem
großen Ziel die Special Olympics in
Berlin auch wenn es Leuchtturmprojekte
sind an denen orientiert man sich ja und
dann kann es auch weitergehen ne und vor
ein Leuchtturm ist kann man noch einen
zweiten Boden
[Gelächter]
die Welt spielen nach Hamburg zu holen
so wie die Kinopremiere wird wohl Teams
Traum bleiben für Berlin aber haben sich
er und die drei anderen Sportler
qualifiziert all inclusive zeigt ihren
Weg dorthin aus einem Blickwinkel den
nicht behinderte Menschen oft nicht
sehen auch deshalb ist der Film nicht
nur Liebens sondern eben auch sehenswert
für Menschen mit Behinderungen können
Sie lebensverändern gar lebensrettend
sein assistenzhunde und sie geht das
gleiche der 37 Grad Reportage nicht ohne
meinen Hund
um 0 Uhr gibt es dann unsere Update mit
Gundula Krause bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend zwischen die Hochs Viola und
xamara schummelt sich ja schon seit
Tagen dieses Tief Heinrich das bringt
Wolken mit Regenschauer und auch
Gewitter die Temperaturen heute Nacht
sinken in der Mitte Deutschlands bis auf
14 Grad 6 Grad werden es in
Schleswig-Holstein und auch heute Nacht
fällt noch weitere Regen hier vor allen
Dingen im Nordosten am Anfang kann auch
noch mal ein Gewitter dabei sein in der
zweiten Nachthälfte bildet sich in
Schleswig-Holstein aber auch in Bayern
vielleicht sogar in Baden-Württemberg
etwas Nebel und wenn der sich morgen
früh aufgelöst hat dann scheint die
Sonne ganz im Süden und ganz im Norden
strahlend über der Mitte sind die Wolken
dichter und besonders am Nachmittag kann
es über den Bergen einzelne Regenschauer
und Gewitter geben der Wind kommt noch
was nördlichen Richtung und das merken
sie wieder vor allen Dingen an der
Nordsee denn dort bleibt es kühl mit nur
16 Grad sonst liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen an der Ostsee und
rund um die Mittelgebirge soweit 20 bis
23 am Alpenrand bei 25 Grad sonst sind
sommerliche 25 bis 28 Grad möglich und
in den nächsten Tagen wird es immer
wärmer am Samstag erwarten uns
Höchsttemperatur von 23 Grad an der
Ostsee bis zu 31 Grad am Main und am
Rhein ansonsten ändert sich beim Wetter
wenig es gibt allerdings heftigere
Gewitter am Donnerstag in der Mitte und
im Süden Deutschlands am Freitag und am
Samstag beschränken sich die Gewitter
dann wieder auf den Südosten guten Abend